il danse il peut vous servir un verre et
même discuter avec les clients
voici un un bep un barman robot du
restaurant 1,16 de sherbrooke ouest à
montréal
arrivé de france il ya 22 ans
l'entrepreneur soit offrir une
expérience qui le distingue de ses
concurrents la gastronomie est
et évolue énormément à montréal et ça
c'est très positif
du coup j ai bon ok la gastronomie c'est
pas un combat que je vais pouvoir gagner
parce que j'ai pas forcément je suis pas
assez connus où les gens s'attaquent
connaissent pas c'est mon parcours et
j'ai dit je vais essayer de me démarquer
par autre chose
à l'étagé dial leicester 1 au sous-sol
leur robot barman pour animer la piste
de danse
ça va me permettre d'attirer une
curiosité et puis quand nos clients vont
venir
l'idée c'est voilà on les fait sourire
on leur fait découvrir une nouvelle
expérience avec le robot aujourd'hui
représentent 80% des dû faire venir dans
le restaurant bonjour est ce que je peux
avoir une coupe de champagne
mais le robot ne remplacera jamais un
humain il n'est conçu que pour divertir
son public
merci beaucoup ici vincent maisonneuve
radio canada montréal